one thing I wanted to bring up was uh
last year we lost uh one of the most
important people that ever worked on the
show Bill T yes bill tll was a legendary
prop master who looked just if you want
a visual Bill tll started with us and
was with us for years and years and
years and years and Bill Tall looked
like a Nordic God I mean very tall
incredible build incredibly handsome
face yeah um and then we started using
in sketches so you might you could look
him up later on yeah funny sketches long
long white hair and he looked like he
could you could put him in a Thor
costume and he could say you trespass
here I mean he had that amazing look
deep voice too yeah but he would do
anything you would do anything and at
that point in the show like you know
sometimes it felt like we were almost at
War because there were people on the
staff who just were like why are we
doing this key screen behind the
band or whatever weird thing trying all
this weird stuff trying all this stuff
and then there were people like Frank
like who would do anything and and think
of I I got something for Alex Rocco
You're Gonna Love It Whatever and Bill
tell I remember I'll just tell one quick
bill story like so we won the the
Rangers won the Stanley Cup in 1994 and
so I had this idea to have like a
dancing a running around Stanley Cup
like a live Stanley
anthropomorph the Stanley Cup is to life
and is dancing around in our and of
course because I was a you know a big
baby I I wanted the a giant Stanley Cup
but to have like tidy whes visible at
the bottom so the legs are really cute
but he's wearing tidy whes and it's kind
of disturbing yeah so but I had this
idea literally at like two in the
morning and like Brian Leech from the
Rangers was going to be on the show the
next day and so I call you know and the
writers were all there laughing about
this and I call like the wardrob
Department like what the are you
talking about that's not going to happen
you can't do that then I call Bill T
he's like okay yeah okay so we'll uh
yeah you want me to build like a whole
thing okay so it's like eight Le how
many levels are there and it's like 3 in
the morning and so he gets right to work
and then the only thing that he can't
figure out is the Stanley Cup has like
this bowl this big silver bowl on top so
B calls the Rainbow Room finds out that
they have a silver bowl he goes up there
which is by way for anyone who doesn't
know one of the most Swanky Swanky like
incredible Elite places people rich
people have their weddings in the
rainbow room so he goes to the Rainbow
Room go to the Rainbow Room hey you guys
got a you guys got a silver bowl I need
it for a guy wearing underwear uh
Stanley Cup thing and and so the guy he
gets the manager of the place and like
well we kind of need that ball listen
what what can I do how can I get the
silver ball and believe and literally
the guy says well I there there's a kind
of hot security guard downstairs and can
you if you can get me her number set me
up uh so I can call her I'll give you
the bowl so he goes down to the ground
floor of course he does talks to the
security guard lady says there's a guy
on rain room and uh and he gets the
number and he goes back upstairs and
comes back with the bowl and this is
like on no sleep no sleep unbel and this
is and and the whole point is that like
that was the spirit of the show that was
the spirit of show and like chil's here
another long time he's I I call chills
the warrior uh because he's still I
shoot things now I'm in different
countries for this thing I'm doing for
HBO Max and chills he was there yeah uh
get it but one of the things was really
this I'll say this and then because we
have so much to talk about but we were
no but we were always no no sorry we
were always this is just going to have
to be a 7- hour episode but um we were
always uh this is what I remember about
Bill Toll was we needed some kind of
crazy looking thing that basically was
going to look like an animal skeleton
but it had a clock for a head or
something and so at rehearsal they
reveal this thing and it looks kind of
perfect and I'm like wow how did you
fake this uh animal skeleton and Bill's
like oh yeah well I you went Upstate New
York I knew a guy who he has a farm and
he told me where all the animals are
buried so he went out at night with a
shovel and dug around till he found a
dead sheep and he dug up all the bones
and reassembled it yeah for the prop
just beyond belief I mean literally he's
a ghoul in the night you know the giant
Moon behind him in a silhouette of him
digging and then assembling bones and
then he just talks about this matter of
fact Leon it's the best episode of
inside Conan you should listen to it
bill and his partner John Ral and I you
know the whole point is that like it was
such a struggle that first year it was
the best job most exciting job I ever
had but it was such a struggle the
network doubting us and we had you know
what I remember very clearly if there
are five things you need to have a
successful television show yeah meaning
the networks behind you um the critics
like you the numbers are strong and then
like a couple things we had none of
those things we had absolutely I
remembered sitting around going let's
see what are the things you need and
then making a list of the five and going
nope nope nope nope nope nope all we had
was a great show we did have a and a
great you know really niick you know was
really nice uh was that we made it to
that first summer and suddenly colleges
got out yeah and all of a sudden we had
these audiences that were fine and if we
did something really funny they would
laugh but it was always touch and go and
then suddenly um I walked out would have
been June of 1994 after this slog this
crazy slog which started the summer
before and went all the way into the
following sum so it was a solid year of
no sleeping always worrying um people on
the street telling me to drop dead you
know oh my God and and um yeah and uh
those were Network
executive it's just I thought it was bad
for
but yeah they were worried I didn't get
the message um it'll make them stronger
it's okay um he's over there he's in
Central Park South get him thanks Lauren
no problem it'll toughen him up now
about my
money um I my getaway car needs a better
driver so uh but I remember that walking
out one day to do the warm-up because I
would do the warm-up before the show and
uh I came out to do the warm-up and the
the minute the crowd saw me they were
yes yeah whoa and I I was looking behind
me like uh is Jerry Seinfeld standing
behind me what what what's happening
this was it was really is interesting uh
all these people who were criticizing
you MH I realize now they were not the
audience no like cuz I've spoken to
people since who like talk about you in
the first year and they're like I loved
him the first year yeah he was a little
nervous but it was all from just
humility of being excited to be on
television right he was so sweet and
these were just like the silent section
of the audience that didn't have you
know access to the internet or whatever
was going on back then no internet no I
mean there was barely would have been
nice if there was an internet there was
like a uset forum that we all obsessed
on at some point but uh but yeah I mean
and uh yeah there was there was an
audience from the beginning we just
didn't know we hear it now because I
hear it from the haters and the m not
the haters the bill haters and the
melanes and all these people that say oh
I loved it and my response is always the
same which is why couldn't you have been
famous then why couldn't you have been
as famous then as you are now and you
could have said something I know um but
they were 11 well we did have Dave who
came on to the show that was the biggest
thing that ever happened yeah that was
February of 94 that was huge yes and he
had the he said it backstage and then he
said it to your face which is what
really mattered on television how great
the show was and that changed a lot of
took a lot of pressure off the network
but the last thing I want to say about
Bill just in general bill bill just that
like for people who work on a show like
this or any movie Set you know you could
you could have the opinion that you know
H my job's not that important there's a
finite amount of effect that I can have
on a show but like it's not true if if
people are supportive of the creative
people at the top and they give off that
vibe that they believe in you and that
they you know and that they'll do
anything for you like Bill and other
people people from that staff it makes
an enormous difference yeah and I say
you know and not to embarrass him
because I know he's right outside this
door because he still works with us but
you know Jason shalmi who you mentioned
is the same kind of person who started
with us as an intern but right I swear
to God if he if Jason thought it was if
he sensed that it was important for us
doing something comedically whether it's
now for the podcast or for a travel show
I'm doing for HBO Max whatever and it
involved him getting shot at Max now
yeah the program okay whatever I like to
throw the HBO in to let people know that
it's a good it's actually
quality it's not pornography yeah when
you say I'm on when you just say Max
people think oh well it's people
guess whack off to this yeah I've never
been able to whack off the cona this is
exciting he's really evolved like they
say his porn is so
creative all the all the furniture in
the room is talking
too the guy and the girl are going at it
and then the couch is like yeah what a
schlong um quiet couchy I'm losing my
concentration but I like that porn with
anthrop wow he's really giving it to her
shut up alarm clock the pizza's watching
the pizza's watching and rubbing its
nipples which your J finally I have a
line which is the pizza's rubbing its
pepperoni
nipples oh I love
it um new meaning to the word food porn
yeah
exactly but uh but no if Jason thought
it was important and he you know I was
just with him we were shooting in South
America and he's like I think if he
thought this was important to me or
somehow important to the comedy but it
involved him running across yeah a
firing line where actual ammunition is
being shot he would do it yeah and um
which is my point is that he's stupid
no no my my point is that it's he makes
you like this the last day I was on the
show I had to give a speech which was
painful as can be because I loved the
show so much and I remember saying I
thanked everybody and I said there are
people in this room who have said Conan
and I have inspired them to do great
work and I just wanted to tell everybody
you you inspired us and that's really
true a guy like Jason a guy like so many
people who um they have your back and
it's makes all the difference in the
world and I I do think in the light of
it's it's a great message too that
people you know in the light of all
these strikes and everything and people
say well it just comes down to Commerce
and money and yes are is money part of
it of course it is but yeah when you see
the level of when when people get
excited creatively and then other people
around them whether it's people working
cameras pulling cables but they're
excited too and they're kind of going
the extra mile to make it happen such a
difference and then it becomes
kind of like a religious experience in a
weird way it becomes spiritual and you
were making something and then you get
the money and you don't share it with
anybody
[Laughter]
that